c'était une première depuis 2016 le 25
janvier dernier au palais de maba che
d'istanbul
une délégation de diplomates grecque est
reçu par le numéro deux du ministère des
affaires étrangères turc sedat tonale au
cours de cette réunion
aucune avancée n'a été annoncée les deux
pays n'arrivant même pas à se mettre
d'accord sur les sujets à aborder
il faut dire que la méfiance est
toujours de rigueur entre ses voisins
après plusieurs années de crispation
preuve en est le jour de ses premiers
pourparlers
la ministre française désarmé florence
parle ici à athènes un contrat pour
l'achat par la grèce de 18 avions de
combat rafale à la france le choix de
l'achat des rafale français souligne le
caractère stratégique des relations
greco française et le plein soutien de
la france à nos côtés face à tout défi
aux menaces paris a directement soutenu
athènes après qu'ankara organisées ces
derniers mois plusieurs missions
d'exploration gazière dans les eaux
grecques provoquant la colère du
président sur la france et souvent à
l'ordre du jour je ne veux pas donner de
noms mais j'y suis obligé parce qu'il
s'en prend souvent à moi ce n'est pas
avec notre peuple midi nous avons des
problèmes avec art doan monsieur macron
vous n'avez pas fini d'avoir des ennuis
avec moi le 11 décembre bruxelles
décident finalement de sanctionner la
turquie pour ses actions illégales et
agressive en méditerranée contre la
grèce et chypre
conséquence en quarts à multiplie depuis
les gestes d'apaisement 2020 était
problématique en ce qui concerne les
relations entre la turquie et l'union
européenne
une volonté politique est apparu pour
créer une atmosphère positive à la suite
du sommet de l'ue en décembre
nous avons eu l'occasion d'établir un
meilleur dialogue une autre bas étage et
la reprise annoncée des par les ex
oratoire direct entre la turquie et la
grèce ces efforts doivent être maintenus
les intentions les annonces doit être
traduite en initiative du côté de l'otan
dont les deux pays sont membres
son secrétaire général s'est dit lundi
préoccupé par le comportement de la
turquie notamment méditerranée orientale
mais ankara reste selon ses mots un
allié important dans la lutte contre des
sèche
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des 30 pays de l'otan se réuniront les
23 et 24 mars